Let's try our hand at interpreting function definitions.
I'll do the first part, you fill in the rest.
In JavaScript, function definitions are top level elements of a JavaScript program.
They're not statements and they're not expressions,
so we're going to have a new evaluation function, evaluate elements.
Here's the abstract syntax tree for the element, here's the current environment.
As usual, we get the type of our tree node by looking at part 0.
If it's a function definition, then we're going to pull out the function name,
the function parameters, the function body,
and then we're going to make up a function value out of that.
It's going to be a for tuple, and then we're going to add that to the environment.
Fill in each one of these 4 blanks so that the code works correctly,
so that we return the right sort of function value and then add it to the environment.